como este de aquí,
y este potencialmente grande de aquí.
Por desgracia, hemos empezado a descubrir saqueo a gran escala en los sitios,
como el que ven aquí.
Muchos sitios en Perú están amenazados,
pero lo genial es que estos datos
serán compartidos con los arqueólogos
que protegen estos sitios.
Estuve en Perú, reunida con el Ministro de Cultura
y con la UNESCO.
Estaremos colaborando estrechamente con ellos.
Solo para que sepan,
el sitio estará en inglés y castellano,
algo absolutamente esencial para asegurarnos
de que pueda participar gente de Perú y de toda América Latina.
Nuestro investigador codirector del proyecto es el caballero que ven aquí,
el Dr. Luis Jaime Castillo,
profesor de la Universidad Católica.
Como respetado arqueólogo peruano y exviceministro,
el Dr. Castillo nos ayudará a coordinar y compartir los datos con los arqueólogos
para que puedan explorar estos sitios en el terreno.
Él también dirige este programa increíble de mapeo con drones,
algunas de las imágenes que pueden ver detrás de mí, aquí y aquí.
Y estos datos se incorporarán a la plataforma,
y él también ayudará con las imágenes de los nuevos sitios que Uds. encuentren.
Nuestro socio en el terreno
que nos ayudará con la educación, la divulgación,
así como con la preservación del sitio,
es la Iniciativa de Preservación Sustentable [SPI],
a cargo del Dr. Larry Coben.
Alguno de Uds. puede no estar al tanto
de que algunas de las comunidades más pobres del mundo
coexisten con algunos de los sitios arqueológicos más conocidos del mundo.
El SPI ayuda
a dar poder a esas personas,
por lo general a mujeres,
con nuevos enfoques económicos y formación empresarial.
Les enseñan a crear bellas artesanías
que luego venden a los turistas.
Esto permite a las mujeres valorar su patrimonio cultural
y apropiarse de eso.
Tuve la oportunidad de pasar algún tiempo con 24 de estas mujeres
en un sitio arqueológico conocido llamado Pachacamac, a las afueras de Lima.
Estas mujeres eran increíblemente inspiradoras,
y lo bueno es que el SPI nos ayudará a transformar las comunidades
cercanas a los sitios que Uds. descubran.
Perú es solo el comienzo.
Expandiremos esta plataforma al mundo,
pero ya recibimos miles de emails
de gente de todo el mundo -- profesores, educadores, estudiantes,
y otros arqueólogos -- a quienes les entusiasma participar.
De hecho, ya han sugerido lugares increíbles para que descubramos,
incluyendo la Atlántida.
No sé si vamos a buscar la Atlántida,
pero nunca se sabe.
Siento mucho entusiasmo de lanzar esta plataforma.
El lanzamiento formal será a fin de año.
Debo decir que
si lo que mi equipo ha descubierto en las últimas semanas es un indicio,
lo que el mundo descubrirá va más allá de la imaginación.
Asegúrese de aferrarse a sus alpacas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.